Salam alaikum warahmatullahi better care
to brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to our first episode of Salam
dining we're gonna be heading to Dallas
diner in Acton in between afternoon
Shepherds Bush we've got a special guest
waiting for us we're gonna review this
place and tell you guys how good it
tastes and how halal it is follow me
okay brother and sister so we are inside
that oz diner will he offer for menus
they've given us free one for you one
for me and one for the guy behind the
camera but you cannot see him oh by the
way we've got our guests undisputed his
style is incredible
his defense is impeccable
one of the G's in the hood halal of
course tree so when you come in brother
sisters inside this is closed is your
but this is the outside garden be
he is more I don't really feel it more I
don't know peaceful if that makes sense
you feel more relaxed with the water
noise in the background I'm gonna I'm
gonna go my same regular buffalo chicken
burger and can I have sweet potato chips
without and Sylla chips
can I get the starter I'm gonna start
spitting oh sorry the special yeah
stir-fry and yeah okay
mango thing you had yeah we didn't want
any stars because usually what would
usually review how long it is between
the starts and the mains meal to come is
usually where the starter comes and then
main look comes like 20 minutes or late
when you've eaten a bit you start
getting full and that affects you know
then you can't eat the main no you get
it so we're a bit critical in that it's
nice so anyways putting a popular
science going on here we have to this is
very serious along dining please let's
talk about that you and hunting all
right you and hunting I saw a picture of
him looking very crazy with a what was
it coming out was the day he had the
deer was it would carry on your
shoulders of it yeah it's called a
murder book what it's called a murder
book the days
you know if there's vegetarian
tree-hugging they're gonna be actually
the first time I've been hunting and up
in Scotland well no no way no no way
went before but we're into hunting there
but yeah so he's gotta burn Scotland
yeah and Scott is legal so you're
talking about we ya know I've been your
way before a few times yeah and we done
expeditions there okay but this
expedition was in Scotland okay and we
were able to go hunting with someone
who's got the accreditation okay so
Reuben we're gonna rock a real rifle
yeah
dangerous and my father's gonna be on
your case so it was so how did it happen
that what this is did you hit the animal
and as far as I remember it was 125
meters yeah but it was a long long long
day I mean I we went out
three in the morning yeah and we went to
all these little walk you do like they
call it stalking you're like walking
really quiet then you go to these places
they go high chairs yeah high seats
where they are and you basically go and
sit in them and and you can observe
everything around and you just sit there
and wait wait wait until a deer or they
call robots a piece now if they got
these policies different times of years
you can shoot me or difficulties you
know yeah in danger yeah so we weren't
allowed to shoot any females in this
time okay
yeah feminists will be happy yep so we
were going for the the male the male
deers and the guy with us his name was
Michael yeah pretty decent guy man
they're really good he does this all the
time we had to wait a few hours here so
I literally nodding off he said to me
just race just good sleep I'll wake you
up when I see one so all right I'll do
that yeah I mean we did about four hours
yeah I didn't see nothing we did see one
or two but they're so far away and once
we saw something but we couldn't catch
it
after that we couldn't see it think so
literally my time is about to finish I
need to pain for this time so soon
yeah regardless if you shoot a deer or
not your pain
yeah and it's not little money it's a
decent amount of money and so he was
basically using that but he was asleep
he was making two up no yeah I was kind
of sad 2000 years later for an hour 5
hours almost gone
Nichkhun is to walk back to the car
yeah so we're not gonna get anything
here but God that Allah we came to one
just a dua forest and I'm walking
walking leave quietly quietly and then
it goes and then he gets his little mano
a little telescope thing you know [ __ ]
you get this let's go pal there's a me
yeah and like this is mom that's my
first in a short yeah and even when to
target practice I was taking my time
no you need to control your breathing
and everything so you move your
breathing goes up and down yeah we meant
to shoot with your heartbeat so you're
kind of timing yeah
so I did that took my time the day
before but now it's pressure you got the
deer standing there too much quality of
got to me
yeah exactly so I'm poor I put down the
gun I'm looking and then he moved behind
me to take a shot when he moved the deer
noticed zone decently goes and there it
looks towards us here and then he goes
to me you better shoot now yeah she was
gonna go it's gonna be okay right
and I was told you to shoot mainly near
the neck area let's write up Nick the
front shoulder yeah yeah shoot it there
and then basically you drop yeah and
that's the easiest way thing obviously
as Muslims we say bismillah Allahu I put
on then shoot yeah but I thought if I
aim for that little target there so I
can eat it okay
and it's also we're not shooting for
father cause what if the animal dad when
you shoot it but the whole point is to
like it no yeah so that's I find that
mother I mean obviously normal school
training is by halal is to sit the
throat and say bismillah yeah but when
you're hunting if you would bow and
arrow with a rifle and so forth as long
as you make the intentions they
determine long when you shoot then it's
fine in fact even some scholars say that
if you kind of forget in the moment say
this mean there's no
you had the intention when he went out
for hunting that you're going it for
collecting food and you say bismillah
before starting your journey then that
should be sufficient as well salmon
speed 11 minutes what is banana milk and
chai tea hmm okay that's why he doesn't
taste anything it's nice you know what
in this place that we're doing this
drink watermelon lime strawberry and ice
especially when it's hot in summer yeah
amazing looks good okay so what side of
it is 352 so it took 19 minutes 90
minutes to come here okay we'll talk
about that then actually sorting stuff I
wasn't asking it's beef
yeah so beef oh yeah be surprised
this is like a love-hate relationship
this doesn't look like sweet potato pie
yeah they forgot excuse them okay so
basically the Buffalo Chip in high order
usually comes in a bun yeah but it's
missed to eat that and you can eat this
at guys roll bar prefer like this for
some reason I feel like they put more
chicken in it when I asked for a wrap
yeah anyway so let me try those but it's
not bad let's call the Tabasco sauce
we're in it we have this shared this or
no it's funny actually I was listening
to a lecture today yeah and the chef
reminded you mentioned that you're
talking about the positive Baraka yeah
it's a concept that generally
non-muslims don't understand or it's
very hard to explain because in in the
dunya in general to get more you ever do
more yeah you're gonna you want to work
hard to get what you want to get yeah
but the concept Baraka is to do list and
it get more yeah it doesn't make sense
then
but sort of some invention mentions in
Walden and idea for example he mentioned
that were paraphrase that when you when
you when you share food where was the
available one is enough for two yes
what's the 3 a 2 is for three but that's
great for who yeah and and the show host
mention a little Side Story to that and
it go because so how we used to come and
this is the Haditha one feeds against
allah forgives energy since some of they
say oh really
yeah some of the hobbies to come to the
Sudan and I used to complain and it's a
it's a la
stopping us from getting forgiveness
because I haven't had guests come to my
the last three days two days that's how
regular they were in getting gifts
coming to the house and he said not just
coming and sitting down the house got
feeding them and so he said that it's
not that a guest comes along anything
I'll know how to make more food no if
you have glove cool enough understand
the concept Baraka what you cook for
your family already is enough a few more
people that come along to be sufficient
always promised sister's finished eating
hundra was nice all gonna be nice bottom
up in our set points Aramis hold it on
top of this so we have five fields that
we check that's more with the quality
and we have five nanami's yeah see how
the time keeping in mind that they will
not move so you take westerns I would
say half an hour that is common at
playing half an hour
it's okay yeah is to teammate big
warrior is not a lot so yeah kind of
salsa question I don't know what it is
but it is a dementing well as a creative
area it could have been foster oh yeah
oh yeah I would say how maybe should
work about if we style it differently
that's better question for you think
okay but not to get something - usually
when it comes of portions if it's too
much music experiment oh really yeah so
if it's a portion is too much we don't
give an edge with all this back okay
from of the portion would you say the
same thing I don't know have you said
too much you are I don't know that's in
the net no I don't know I would say just
what we find there they over
I think next we fit there so but as I
said if it's it wasn't so smoothly
hangin off before I mean if you
attribute to people to people with a
drink and install okay what dispelling
infertility
yeah okay well we did what would you
vote tell me I've been on your mind I
can feel I would do it for me personally
just it wasn't right
yeah so I'm truly feeling up in Vienna
start pushing price how's the price okay
especially here and my one thought you
were a little 690 that's common is the
Mambo I mean I think my love I need a
new lead
yeah yeah but you said I don't know you
thought that there that being said yeah
it's a free from fifty like a former get
chicken I think there's no definitely
isn't post-op or price then literally
hundreds and post well 100 but mostly
the food how's Italy my role like this
specific to here yet yeah and I've tried
a few other stuff before yeah I like
this
how's it gonna give it yeah very nice
[ __ ]
I mean I like to maybe people don't want
any money yeah you tell me that tell
them advance yeah don't put it yeah but
a buffalo chicken boom very nice okay
that would be posing to eat yeah okay
okay so now that was our quality but
obviously you guys that you know what
makes us unique and different you have
we review how palaces now as far as I
know maybe was put in about me yeah
putting enough yeah that's one star yeah
do they finish it no there is inside
ended
okay they don't matter given hot start
analysis okay this party are they live
in I've ever seen time they paid no spot
for that it it should I'll go no no we
need to get a stop for them yeah so what
did you do we do Aramis lose it
same flavor it's not they'd have not
even using someone's game thanks we will
never do this please I don't have a
craving me our newest machinery yeah
those are for that I also do they have
to find sequences do you have that
credit problem you I provided while
she's one it's a combo they don't have
enough private booth come you know they
have body which is the house will walk
and sit down and not that kind of thing
it's as if their ways to be honest
that's a man like you know mom insisted
that's it that's about it from surround
and you hope you got a very well
hopefully why would even know about that
yes we can make sure anything a bunch of
that matriarchal amici videos here and I
will chosen charity votes as you guys
own a salon tanning we have our chosen
organization that we try to help them on
the table last time you know Community
Foundation and the lot but now we work
in trauma with Sonam as you guys know
and Salam if I were trying to raise
funds for its operation cause as you
know the studios have set up so the link
is there you can donate that well you
can one pound two pounds whatever you're
a big ball of you know find in there so
this is comfortable should share with
your friends and family I hope you
benefited if you want to review another
place comment in the section below
there's no where and when and we will
check it out shower until you guys how
hard is it on me I'm sorry what what is
it
completely oh yeah that's about justice
or episodes coming very soon now